- You know what, you told me that we
weren't bringing my
family into this! (laughs)
- [Voiceover] Sorry, I know!
(logo whooshes)
(hinge squeaks)
(upbeat music)
(whooshing)
- I like would you
rather cause I feel like
you can tell a lot by people's choices.
- I feel like I have to
think everything through,
and like make sure I'm
making the right decision
as if it's gonna happen in real life.
(whooshing)
- Ahh!
- One pull, you're done.
But jabbing the toothpick
and then kicking something?
It's just insult to injury.
- I feel like honestly, my
big toe is so sensitive,
if I hit anything with
it, like, I go crazy.
- I'm gonna go with the second one,
because it doesn't say how hard
I need to kick my foot against the wall.
(whooshing)
(upbeat music)
- Are there laws against
not having sex with a goat?
- Well, if we're saying that
sex is a very loose definition,
then I'll say that I'll
have sex with the goat
and no one will know.
- I'd much rather live with
people thinking something
about me and me knowing the truth,
than having done something
that feels awful.
- Y'all can go ahead and
think I had sex with a goat.
But I don't wanna actually have sex,
how would I have this goat sex?
(whooshing)
(upbeat music)
- Oh, definitely vaginas for ears.
That's an easy one. (laughs)
- That would be inconvenient, vagina ears.
100%, I'd just wear earmuffs all the time.
- I got 10 fingers and
I don't want 10 dicks.
- I'm like Edward's Penishands
or something like that?
Like I couldn't touch anyone,
who would wanna love me?
(whooshing)
(upbeat music)
- What's life as a potato, really?
- I don't wanna be a potato.
- In a past life, I certainly
was already a potato.
So I don't think this
question applies to me.
- I would go with eat a potato
and then I would just
stop eating potatoes.
(whooshing)
(upbeat music)
- Oh. (groans)
- No, my parents watch these videos!
- But by process of elimination,
I'm not doing the first one.
So I'm doing the second one. (laughs)
- I feel like that's like a commitment
if I have to watch them
every single day of my life?
So um, I'm just gonna be
a very passive third wheel
in this threesome.
- I'm not gonna answer,
I can't answer that!
- I'll figure it out, but I do not want
to (bleep) my parents, I
don't, that's not gonna happen.
- I need a mouthwash
question for that question.
- I'd rather just jump off a building
than do any of those things.
(whooshing)
- How do you think of these things?
These questions are crazy.
But very good.
- It's okay, but it's not okay.
- The potato thing made
me think a lot, you know?
I don't think being a
potato would be that bad.
I really don't.
(upbeat music)
(logo whooshes)
(hinge squeaks)